hello to all my friends had flicked in
the city when they finally get to meet
the guy use the voice behind Mario and
of course plastic feel to be one of
game's most iconic characters you know
it's such an incredible gift and it's
such a joy to do the to the voice and
then to come to comic-con and London
here see these amazing fans
I feel like father Christmas on Boxing
Day I played these great games it's so
much fun tonight I love that the games
are all fun and a wholesome and great
pleasure and it should be a part of this
is really exciting how amazing it all
started when you Christ an audition 20
years ago 20 years ago I wasn't invited
I'd knocked in the door he said start
talking and when you run out of things
to say
that's your audition and it's 23 years
later and I still haven't started to
stop talking yet what was it like when
you start stop seeing Mario in real time
you know that was an amazing technology
because I I had things glued to my face
everywhere and I were talking hello I'm
a Mario and and you know seeing people
react because I could see them through a
hidden a camera and a hidden microphone
I can say oh look get a beautiful
princess my money oh and you got the
microphone and you'd say are you talking
to me oh yes you're the princess right
you know that the interaction is
wonderful people were so amazed and
they're still amazed I still do it from
my home and my little bunny slippers I'm
gonna be talking to people at at Festa
Games in in Santiago Chile and in
comic-con in San Diego I'll be in my
bunny slippers and a Nintendo World
store and they'll be seeing Mario saying
hello
and now Luigi - cause it's here Luigi Oh
what is it the voices of Mario and Luigi
come from you know I just said they came
from actually William Shakespeare I was
I did send you the shroom ten or fifteen
years before this and I was sitting
there I've walked crash the audition he
said you're an Italian plumber from
Brooklyn make up a voice make up a game
and when start talking when you stop
talking that's your audition and I
thought you know Italian plumber from
Brooklyn hey I'm under your sink don't
bother me here right you know and I
thought no do something nicer and I had
done Gremio intending it is true at a
repertory company a few years before and
a grêmio grêmio was the mayor of a city
and Petruchio was an American GI going
back to Italy to find a wife and he was
a nice early Italian guy Doka like it is
and I thought make it a little bit
younger make it more fun because that
guy was all about bubbly fun and try
that out and I'm sitting there thinking
about it but I don't know anything about
video games
I hear action I turn to the camera I say
hello I'm a Mario it's make the beats
abide together you go get some sausage I
get some spaghetti meatball
we put spaghetti meatball in the sausage
in the pizza can I chase you the pizza
if I catch you the pizza you gotta eat
the pizza then we gotta make a pizza you
gotta chase me me the pizza yeah and I
just everything you know running the
kitchen sink down the stream it just
went on and on but it is so much fun you
know and the characters for all these
years it's still fresh every day it's
still joyful and fun every
so and coming to comic-con is great fun
you know all these beautiful people and
people are having so much fun now
what your own personality be brought to
Mario and Luigi well I think actually
they bring personality to me they bring
joy fun mario has this incredible a
sense of courage and bravery and facing
every challenge in life with a who which
I want to be more like that and of
course Luigi you know a little more team
a little bit that sure I'm not shy my my
Mario but this year I'm coming into my
own need a spark like you know so it's
always that process of having fun and
growing and being strong you know and a
crossbody Oh Betty Betty dropping
Britney
maybe maybe ski and baby man you like to
know all the many games that you've made
over the years but the ones that
particularly stand out really remember
you know when we recorded Mario 64 in
1996 he was the first time the voice
went into the game and just that session
was so magical just wet everything was
brand new what do we do when someone
puts the controller down well maybe he
falls asleep how about my money you know
and so everything was brand new but
every time I see a new Mario game I just
came from e3 and I saw Mario Kart 8 in
Super Mario 3d World and just seeing
them it's like I watch and I get
goosebumps and I'm in so excited to see
there might be I love the characters so
much and the games every time you play a
game it's a brand new world and a
it's absolutely lovely how are you at
playing the games yourself you know I
play them all and I get about a few
levels in and when mr. Miyamoto and his
creative teams say okay now it's gonna
get a little harder I it takes me longer
longer longer and then I'm like I hit
the roof I hit the roof you know it's
lots of fun and do you ever talk to
yourself in one of the Mario or Luigi
voices at all because of course we all
kind of talk to ourselves during the day
that way a person would have to be
insane to talk to themselves that way I
can't believe you would ask me yes I do
every single morning when I'm in a good
mood I back i'mma go here we go okie
dokie okie go you know that sort of
thing and I always hear that mr. Kondo
is incredible music the Nightman minute
then you know it kind of gives me that
perky little beginning today I love that
yeah it's it I alway day talk to myself
that way imagine you doing that now and
what about best lines as well that
you've had over the years or the ones
that you can't think oh I love saying
thank you very much for playing my games
here we go Mario time than a panther and
oh we love them all I can't go without
asking you very quickly about Arnie the
dinosaur in nine months as well what do
you remember about that experience well
you know that was very fun
just like the Mario experience you know
at when I did Mario it was supposed to
be the real-time animation for one trade
Show CES 23 years ago and you see it's
not gone into 23 years in Arne there was
no singing and no it was like a possible
singing and and there was no fight scene
and I'm sitting around with the stunt
guys and I like you know because they're
shooting other scenes the other room I
said so what happens if I if I we had a
fight into the stuntmen go a fight a
fight well I don't know we can do a
fight
and so we rehearsed this fight for Chris
Columbus and a Wack Wack grabbed the
dinosaur by the tail spin him around you
know and then of course one of us kind
of slips a little bit runs knocks into
this toy store amazing chest and it
starts toppling like that and it came so
close to falling over which of course
would have ended my world completely
right there and pissed Columbus watches
the whole fight scene he goes
well when I'm remaking episodes of
Bonanza maybe we can do that fight scene
you know and we all laugh like that oh
well at least at least I tried you know
and he turned to the pretties you guys
what are we doing on Wednesday and so I
came back for Wednesday and we shot that
fight scene you know Loeb it's for you
and me we all wouldn't be playable the
you know it's just like a really fun fun
fun I love every character I play but
you know of course for me and Mario is
is the joy of my life
is there anything that you haven't done
yet that you'd really love to do either
in Mario's world or anything else I just
look forward to every single opportunity
to do Mario's voice and every time I see
a new game that comes out from Nintendo
I you know I we eat a wonderful sushi
meal and we go and I see these
animations and I go oh my goodness is
gonna be fun a new leap a new jump and
you hop a new you know sort of a boss to
attack and it's like oh my gosh oh this
is so great or you see them you know
flying or something new in a game it's
like but something new in a game and
every time you know it's gonna be the
most exciting fun game ever so I mean
what a gift to me to be here for so long
doing what I love so much and what about
games coming up as well oh my goodness I
can't wait for Super Mario 3d World I
can't wait for Mario Kart 8 I can't you
know you know and III was really fun
because you could you know fans could
sit in the cart and look like they were
driving it took photographs and
uploading them so you should look for
those not it that was so
and you know and going down the green
pipe you know it was really fun so yeah
all the games and there are gonna be a
lot of games in this year and they're
gonna be so much fun I'm a big lover of
the Wii U and I think the more people
play the Wii U the more they go oh my
goodness the potentials here are
enormous and of course each game that
comes out shows more and more of that
potential and so pretty soon people are
gonna go I have to have that you know
it's I do Charles it's been an absolute
pleasure talking to you what you'd like
to say to your fans I just want to say
thank you very much for playing my games
is England it's a Mario Land yeah thank
you so much
you